unfortunately you know this is the
parallels between beginning games game
game of chess and the modern geopolitics
it's uh very questionable because
putin's game is more of a poker
and he knows how to bluff
this is not just the anniversary of the
berlin walls uh collapse it's also the
anniversary of your yeah
i had this day to celebrate four years
before collapse of berlin wall november
9 1985 i won my world championship title
moscow
and we'd like to think that the uh the
two events are not unlinked talk a
little bit about what are the enduring
lessons of the fight against communism
that we are in uh you know with 25 years
it seems
a couple of worlds ago what are the
lessons that were in the danger of
losing from uh you know long after the
twilight of the cold war
i think we we've forgotten many
important lessons of the cold war
uh i have to say that the when i entered
this field you know in mid-80s as the
newly born world champion it was not as
dangerous so
gorbachev badly needed to reconcile with
the west the soviet economy was
in a terrible shape the oil prices were
sharply uh falling you know thanks to
the cooperation between reagan's
administration and saudis um and uh it
was absolutely clear for
even for soviet politburo that the uh
the the arms race and and in the
competition against the united states on
the global scale
was no longer a plausible option so
gorbachev tried hard and
he made
several attempts to convince
ronald reagan to accept
some some form of peace accord and
thanks to reagan's intuition despite the
advice of all his advice
his administration it's
the state department and the pentagon he
said no in in reykjavik and i think by
saying no in reykjavik reagan
made
uh and and and the eventual collapse of
the soviet union inevitable at such a
short period of time and of course
reykjavik in china it's also a uh uh
it's a it's a symbolic place in 1972
bobby fischer bit boris basket so that
was another sort of the big victory of
the free world in the cold war oh and
and thereby condemning all of us in
grammar school in the 70s to joining
chess clubs
um you know what what was it like to
grow up in the in the soviet system uh
you know both i mean and you were in a
relatively privileged position but can
you talk a little bit about when you say
relatively privileged because of my
chess yeah status uh yes but i mean what
was it like and what was the
psychological effect on on yourself or
people around you yeah
i think certain things is very hard to
describe because to understand them you
have to live with them so it's it's i
was always amazed you know to hear
comparisons in america or western europe
about soviet union and certain
wrongdoings of the governments in the
free world and just without recognizing
that you know it's
soviet union just was a dictatorship
and uh okay i i grew up in these
late 60s 70s early 80s as a teenager
and of course i haven't experienced the
horrors of the stalin's time but you
know it was still the country that was
not free and
thanks to my ability to play chess and
uh the fact is that i was a chess
prodigy i could start traveling abroad
so my first trip to france was when i
was 13. and it was quite a shocking
experience
what was your showing experience that it
you know i don't think that in my
family and i'm not talking about just
you know just very few people but just
so like extended family that's cousins
you know justice
and also among my friends there was no
single person who ever visited the
capitalist country so at age 13 you know
just i became sort of i carried sort of
a sacred knowledge of how people live
there just on other side of iron curtain
so people you know knew that there was
another world they could of course read
some literature that was officially
banned but you could buy it uh they
could listen
to radio liberty or voice of america bbc
and um
they you know it's there was no
there was no more
um
you couldn't find hard believers in in
in in a communist regime so it was all
dying down so my grand grandfather my
mother's mother he was a diehard
communist he died in 1981 and he last
couple of years with big debates because
i was already 17 18 and
and
we were talking about afghanistan
and other things and
he was shocked because he couldn't
understand why you know after him
spending 50 years in the communist party
he had to line up to buy you know butter
and bread so as for him it just it was
mind-boggling so something went wrong
um so that's why the collapse of the
communism of the communist system was
somehow already you know
you know imminent and
and i think this gorbachev's plan was to
not to
remove communism but actually to create
something more plausible without giving
up
the um the uh
the role of the communist party do you
think that uh in the end that there is
no way to do that that i mean you can't
get a it's kind of like being a little
bit pregnant if you give people a little
bit freedom it's it's going to collapse
yeah i think so which i realized but i
don't follow that illusion all the way
but uh no but it's it's i i'm
i don't think that you know you can
divide people you know genetically
saying these nations are not ready to
embrace democracy
and i hear his arguments about russia or
about china but look you know
you have two koreas
if you look at the norse i mean you you
can you come up with a conclusion that
koreans are born to be slaves you know
and they they live in gulag unless you
are aware that there is a north there's
a south the south korea one of the most
you know flourishing economies in asia
and and again it's a democracy and
market economy so i and also in china
you have china on one side but you have
taiwan
so it's a rocky island with the same
people and i'm not even mentioning two
germans so um i think that people have
the same aspirations they want to be
successful they want their kids to have
good education they want to spend some
money to have you know vacation decent
place the moment they're given this
opportunity i don't think you can you
know you can force them back to the to
the commonly stable well you know as as
tom was bringing up you've been uh very
forward and very courageous in speaking
out against putin and other forms of
dictatorship uh creeping fascism
corporatism
what um you're very critical of the
west's engagement with countries like or
with putin with china
what what do you think is wrong about
the way that the west you've written
that uh you know we're willing to trade
with them but we don't draw a line when
they uh
uh obviate civil liberties when they
when they continue to act repressively
what how should we be engaging them
those of us in the free world it's it's
a long story but it's i i i since today
we are talking about the berlin wall so
just we have to go from the back of the
1989 1991
and it's
it was a great moment in history so
everybody was
um a lot younger you know
don't mention that so um
it
we believe that it's it was all over if
in august 1991 you know anybody could
say in moscow or outside of soviet union
and nine years later the kgb lieutenant
colonel would be the president of russia
i think this person would just people
will be laughing so it's just it was
really impossible to to believe that you
know after all these changes you know we
can go back but uh i think the results
of the collapse of the soviet union they
were probably
misread
uh both now inside our inside former
soviet union and also outside so in 1992
the you know one of the best sellers was
the end of history of francis fukuyama
the end of history the liberal democracy
has won that's it
and i think you know this book ignored
the fact that you know that's
every generation you know has to fight
its own berlin wall as ronald reagan
said the freedom is is always one
generation away from extinction so
there's no physical berlin wall but
there are walls
and
the problem of the soviet union
specifically um that was that unlike
germany or nazi germany or imperial
japan
there was no um
process of sort of
cleansing process so the society
couldn't feel
responsibility for the communist crimes
so for the russians was okay that's over
you know and same as in 1918 you know in
in germany we lost the war but maybe
somebody betrayed us and you know it's
the the
while we had some good moments in the
90s under yeltsin but you could feel it
in the 90s that the
building
or trying to to build you know
the system similar to the to do the free
world so with parliament uh was with
presidential power with checks and
balances with independent court system
they failed because russian people
believe that you know the all they
needed is just you know to to have this
you know the voting procedure
and we it would it if we implement that
it will immediately lead to the dramatic
improvement living standards so irony is
that
nobody could see an improvement in the
90s or okay majority couldn't see
while
when putin took over thanks to the
high-level crisis suddenly
life improved and in the mind it's it's
it's a very odd connection but in the
minds of many ordinary people wow that's
a democracy so that's because we now we
we we feel something and then they're uh
they feel loyalty to putin rather than
to democratic institutions absolutely
again how much how much of the problem
with russia is specifically a problem
with putin you i mean you've written
you know that distinct from the soviet
union it is about him he's building a
cult of personality or where the state
revolves around him uh you read about
the sochi olympics that it was a
glorification of him similar to the way
the the berlin olympics were um so if if
putin is gone does the trouble go away
from within russia or what what needs to
happen within the country look um
if dictator goes away i mean it's it
doesn't happen
through the normal you know election
process so that's why you can expect a
turmoil so most likely uprising in
moscow in the capital it will not end up
you know with very peaceful resolution
so because political opposition has been
destroyed and
i don't think you can have anything
worse than putin i mean just all these
threads that putin is the the last
sort of line of defense and if not putin
no no putin is the main problem
putin is is
a paranoid aging dictator who believes
he is russia same way hitler believed he
was germany and it's not surprising that
now kremlin propaganda has been
repeating sort of these the classical
formula hitler's german germany's hitler
now putin's russia russia is putin it's
extremely dangerous because for him his
own collapse means the collapse of the
country and unlike hitler he has his
finger on the nuclear button
he's by far more dangerous threat to the
world peace because it's russia today is
not as old soviet union or not modern
china it's not ideological dictatorship
with politburo central committee of the
communist party it's one man
dictatorship it means that this man if
he believes he is the country he can do
whatever so how should the west or the
free world uh the oecd countries uh nato
the u.s what should they be doing
differently in dealing with putin
because i mean you're not talking about
military engagement but you have written
a lot about economic engagement and
other types of trade policy and things
like that what are what are good ways to
addre you know to kind of bring putin to
keel um okay it's it's this problem is
not uh is
we have been facing this problem for
quite a while
and there's so many mistakes that have
been made
and those mistakes created
an impression for putin and his cronies
and also some of his clients like assad
and others in the world iranian
ayatollahs that the west is weak the
west is not willing to get engaged
so the west will give them anything they
want so this it's you know
before we talk about
you know the right strategy what we what
the free world what the leader leaders
of the world must do i mean let's start
talking about what they must not do i
mean you you cannot project weakness
yes i know that america will never
consider seriously boots on the ground
in ukraine why you are talking about it
why you say publicly you will not do
that so what's who is forcing you yes
and i could start you giving many
examples where just you know they
violated the simplest rules of
negotiations now the letter secret
letter from obama to ayatollahs without
mentioning the fact that you know it's
an insult for the sunni allies and it's
the first time that the united states
and the free world had a great chance of
creating a sunni coalition to stop
sunnis terror
now and you know
stabbing them in the back by writing a
letter to ayatollah by the way this is
not the first letter they never
responded and now
at the time when the nuclear deal is
about to be reached or not i mean he's
asking them to help in isis isis will be
destroyed you need probably more planes
maybe some soldiers bring you know just
it's material resources isis is not a
global threat so it's very local and for
the sake of iranian corporation this
relatively small issue to put you know
at stake you know the the global
cooperation with sunnis and also the
non-proliferation policies it's it's
that's exactly what you're not supposed
to do you you know you've written about
how uh starting with under clinton as
well as under george w bush and under
barack obama you talked about bush being
reckless obama being aimless are who are
the western leaders you think that are
heads of state who have actually
articulated a post-cold war framework
for
uh kind of spreading democracy and
market liberalism i i don't think that
any western leader
even thought about doing that because
again the mood was we won
yeah it's it's many people talk about
let's say clinton's presidency as a
great success yeah
i wouldn't i wouldn't uh doubt certain
you know
the
achievements and economy here but
geopolitically it was the greatest
disaster among all because it's not
about the you know the the the final
position like we look at the chess board
and you say oh i'm still have winning
position yes but you missed mate in two
five times in the row
the game is still on so in 1992 america
was all-powerful it could design the
world that the way
it wanted
in 2000 al qaeda was ready to strike so
what's happened in these eight years
so eight years of complacency of doing
nothing so nobody formulated policies
for russia for former soviet union for
islamic terrorism it requires you know
the global vision the same way as
winston churchill harry truman you know
had this policies designed in 1946 47
you know marshall plan there were there
were plans plans they learned from the
world war ii and they knew that you know
to oppose stalin and to oppose communism
they needed to come up a with a plan
strategy and also leadership
when i hear about potential dangers of
confronting putin today my first
question is is he more dangerous than
joseph style in 1948 for 11 months
american and british plans have been
supplying west berlin
besieged by stalin troops
and joseph stalin
hasn't shot a single american plane why
because harry truman already used
nuclear weapons and stalin as every good
dictator had i'm sure that had this
animal instinct
he knew where he could be
repulsed
so he knew that harry truman would not
play a game it happened in 1962 when
khrushchev recognized that he pushed jfk
to the ropes and ronald reagan and don't
tell me that the soviet union in 1981 82
or 83 was
less powerful than putin's russia today
you have written recently about how
america is hugely important in the world
and that america needs a strong economy
and that economic force will help change
it will help spread democracy and
freedom
markets throughout the world
you've you've talked about how
people in america don't seem to have the
kind of bold
sense of vision of innovation of change
can you talk a little bit about that
what where what happened to that the
idea that we're going to reinvent the
world no i wish i knew so this is this
you know um
you can just look at the at at at the
literature so this is 50s you know
science fiction wasn't the most popular
genre it has disappeared now it's uh
it's either you talk about elves and
magic or it's dystopia
you know it's just all you talk about
machines attacking us so it's there's no
more positive vision of machines
cooperating let me let me push back on
that though because i in uh you know you
talked about 40 years ago
but or you know since
then i mean we've had things like the
internet we've had things like fracking
which has totally uh undermined russia's
ability to dictate oil prices
i mean what you know we yeah i mean does
anybody here think that the world is
less yeah
it's a result of these of the of the
space race the foundation for internet
was
created designed and eventually
developed by the scientists from darpa
defense advanced research project agency
in 1962 and 1963 so it's from packet
switching to the full description of
every element including skype and in
1969 the first signal came for arpanet
from ucla to stanford so are you so this
is what you're talking today it's www
the world war net is uh
commercial application of of technology
has been developed 20 years before which
also was is the thing that makes it
transformative though
we're talking about breaks through
technologies so do we need another cold
war do we need i mean because that's
also talking you know
is that what we need a kind of
regimented goal that society but it's
it's but you know it's 50 uh it's in
2012 you know 50 years after the jfk
speech in the rice university about moon
about this moon project
uh america had no more
rockets just no more uh means to
actually send uh their al
austronauts into the space they had to
use russian but they were also built you
know in the 60s and 70s so i think it's
it's it's constitutes a disaster
uh scientific disaster because
space projects are important not just
for the sake of landing on moon or mars
because of the side effect as we had
gpas we had internet and many other
things that have been developed you know
alongside with the space project so for
instance you know just expedition to
mars which you know has probably 50 50
chance of of safe return of the crew
will force us to do more work on the
diet on the medicine and while today you
know what's
uh people here i'm sure in the room
though but much better than i do what
are the chances of introducing a new
drug so if you have one out of a
thousand you know
the rate of failure you're out of out of
production now if you produce new drugs
or new uh food for the expedition with
50 50 chance of return then one out of
three is already good so this is it's
it's very important that we we have
these projects to energize a society
and not to eliminate risk because it
seems to me that risk now it's as we we
teach kids from the school that failure
is nothing but failure
if you fail you are a failure no i
believe that failure is a way is it's
it's it's a logical move on your way to
success well uh you know as somebody who
fails more often than i succeed i i feel
much better at the discoveries look i
mean we were uh talking earlier in the
evening you said that there's a huge
amount of complacency uh kind of in
what used to be called the free world
does that i mean is this kind of a
marxist analysis of capitalism that we
kind of get fat and lazy because we you
know things come easily after a certain
point um and we fall into an inability
to actually do do take the kinds of risk
or create the kind of innovations that
actually will push us forward it's again
probably you know the
the free world needs challenges you know
definitely
wars or cold war there were challenges
we don't want to see these challenges
again but it's natural that you know we
we have to we have to recognize that you
know the real innovations is not iphone
6 it's apollo 6.
there's a fundamental difference and it
seems to me that again we we
we have multinational corporation that
sittings that are now sitting on
hundreds of billions of dollars of cash
without investing them in in new ideas
so we just i understand paying
shareholders is important but you know
creating new values is is probably more
important
all right and at that point we're going
to turn it over to some questions and
also uh by the way if any of you
are sitting on billions of dollars of
cash i do want to point out that both
atlas and reason are 501c3s that's how
you can take
but um so let's uh go to questions
please so i asked you earlier privately
sir
why you played the sicilian defense to
win your first world chess championship
and you declined to answer and so i just
want to ask that question publicly and
then i want to ask you
how you would apply that to the global
scene today
okay it's the uh
and for those of us who only just it
doesn't matter what is this
it doesn't matter this is this it's the
it's you know uh
it was a game that you know i i was
leading 12 to 11 carpool had to win the
game you know he played with white
because he started the game uh um
to retain the title so i could be happy
with a draw
now the question is why i played very
sharp opening instead of trying to play
very defensive now the answer is very
simple when you reach the climax of any
battle you'd better be on in the
situation that fits your nature so i was
much more comfortable in sharp position
it doesn't matter we play you know we
play a game and uh you know i could win
i could lose it could be a draw but i'm
comfortable and my calculation was right
because at the crucial moment of the
game karpov had to push had to make a
sacrifice but it was against his name he
tried to to improve his position he
wasted time and eventually i could you
know create a powerful counter-attack so
same
you know in politics you know you have
to play the game that fits your
strengths
so and again there's so many um
arguments there's so many trump cards in
the hands of the free world and you have
to start using them
i played i played the
game of chess
yes
unfortunately you know this is the
parallels between beginning games game
game of chess and the modern geopolitics
it's
very questionable because putin's game
is more of a poker
and he knows how to bluff
and that's poker and and he normally he
has a very weak hand
i would say pair of nine
but
he bluffs
and he knows that you know that sets
it's uh you know that oh the is his
opposition always you know try to fold
out the cards so once i said that you
know if putin has this you know pair of
whatever eight nine or ten and he acts
as if he has a flesh real and obama has
a full house and he flashes to the
toilet
here let me ask you i mean do you
do you
do you believe that putin would be
expansionary beyond the uh confines of
the former soviet union and then what is
the challenge that is posed by a country
like china is it similar and kind to the
russian
challenge or is it something very
different um
you know
i think the nature of putin's challenge
today is very much
domestic he has a fundamental problem of
finding the rationale for staying in
power he's in power 15 years and every
dictator who is not relying on
democratic institutions must come up
with
a story a myth
an idea why the hell you're there so
this is for many young russians it's a
question so economy
doesn't offer any more excuses so to the
contrary it all goes down so russian
middle class that that used to uh um see
gradual improvements in the living
standards and
you know it's all money in perks you
know inability to travel around so so
communications
suddenly they just recognize that it all
could you know disappear now putin's
only only rationale is to present
himself as a big hero vladimir the great
the collector of russian lands so putin
the
the man who who is who is who is
restoring the russian empire
again for him it's the the main
audiences inside the country the
propaganda and i could still hear it in
just you know by listening to to to
russian television or just reading the
press
it's it's it's worse than dr gubbel's
it's oral it's so war is peace slavery
is freedom 24 7 it's anti-american and
they keep talking about horrible things
as even using nuclear weapons even putin
himself you know at his later speech
praised nikita khrushchev for making
these threats it's almost quote unquote
when he said that khrushchev you know
was no he acted like a crazy man banging
with yeshua at the united nations but
everybody respected him because they
knew it was crazy and they were afraid
that he would uh throw nuclear missiles
at them that's literally quoting quote
now combine it with his
uh clear statement that all the borders
of the former soviet union so they are
in question
so that's why uh you know he believes
that russia was in its right to
challenge ukrainian borders and others
as well now the question is whether he
could attack estonia latvia that members
of nato article five
my answer is he might do that because he
doesn't have to start over invasion he
could
provoke violence in the russian enclaves
in estonia or in latvia and then you
could see some volunteers crossing the
border at the end of the day it's not
about
invading latvia estonia it's all about
undermining nato
obama had a big speech in tallinn
claiming that united states would behind
estonia nice next day russian
intelligence kidnapped an estonian
officer from estonian territory
dragged him into russia he's now in a
russian jail
waiting for a trial
for espionage next day
why just to show that no protection so
it's all about undermining western
institutions and nato and demonstrating
that the united states is is a paper
tiger it's an empty shell
you